this game has ruined me nothing's fun
compared to this game seriously even
though I've done absolutely everything I
can in this game nothing is more fun
than this game video games have become
pretty realistic but not many games are
as hardcore as escape from tarkov oh
tarkov is easily one of the most
unforgiving games out there one wrong
move and you can lose weeks sometimes
even months of progress and there is
friendly fire no it's me it's me
it's me it's me I'm screaming that it's
me Tim stop looking behind the fridge
what killed you sniper I mean a person
or a sniper at the back I don't know but
tarkov's High skill ceiling makes
getting kills feel way more rewarding
than most games and even with limited
resources an experienced player can do
some serious damage